oui
[Musique]
je suis à chine ratansi bienvenue dans
la première de l'année de going under
grande une première confiné étant donné
que durant les congés les taux de
contamination coronavirus en angleterre
sont devenus les plus élevés au monde
il ya une tentative d'insurrection à
washington et le journaliste et éditeur
julian assange n'a pas été extradé vers
un tribunal de virginie
grâce à la juge vanessa paré d'heures
qu'ils le gardent néanmoins dans une
prison de haute sécurité
ici à londres où selon un rapporteur
spécial de l'onu
il aurait été torturé par les autorités
britanniques celui qui me rejoint
maintenant est un des partenaires
médiatiques de julian assange l'ancien
rédacteur en chef du journal the
guardian alan rusbridger heures son
nouveau livre s'intitule les
informations comment s'en servir que
croire dans un monde de fausses
informations
alan bienvenue dans l'émission ce qui
est triste avec ce nouvel ouvrage c'est
que vous commencez en explique donc que
vous l'avez écrit au pic de la pandémie
on sait désormais que ce n'était pas le
cas qu'est ce que ça fait d'écrire un
livre sur le journalisme pendant le
confinement est bien j'aurais bien aimé
pouvoir être aussi prévoyant le livre a
été écrit au printemps et tout le monde
pensait que c'était le pire moment alors
que bien sûr la situation est encore
pire désormais mais je pense que les
thèmes du livre le journalisme qui les
gens croient et comment les gens savent
en quoi croire sont toujours aussi
pertinent que quand je les écris et je
veux dire dans le titre même du livre on
retrouve la problématique des fausses
informations qui est particulièrement
importante à l'heure actuelle de toute
évidence à cause de je ne sais pas
comment vous évaluerez la dissonance
scientifique à l'heure actuelle en
angleterre et dans le monde contre les
vaccins de big pharma et c'est très bien
je pense que les journalistes ont tout à
fait conscience que pour la première
fois de leur vie
ce qu'ils écrivent pourrait faire la
différence entre la vie et la mort il ya
une gravité dans la conscience de ce
qu'est le journalisme je pense que du
côté du public
il se développe la conscience la peur je
dirais
de ce que c'est que de vivre dans une
société où règne un chaos informationnel
vous ne savez pas si quelque chose a eu
lieu ou non s'il faut croire quelque
chose ou non il ne faut pas longtemps
avant que des pans de la société
s'effondre sur la question de l'argent
dans le journalisme est un fil
conducteur dans le livre vous dites que
les rédactions qui n'ont pas licencier
leurs experts scientifiques et médicaux
pour des raisons budgétaires vont de
toute évidence mieux ben oui on sait que
l'une des réponses à la crise économique
a traversé le journalisme a été de faire
des coupes dans les rédactions
c'est compréhensible car vous avez des
actionnaires ou quelque chose de la
sorte mais en fin de compte cela
implique et que certaines rédactions
n'avez pas quand la crise a frappé des
gens qui s'y connaissait et qui avait
l'autorité pour écrire sur ce sujet et
des lecteurs s'en sont vite aperçus je
pense que c'est une grosse erreur que
d'attaquer de manière très sérieuse
une opération journalistique qui n'est
en fin de compte que la seule chose que
vous avez à vendre ensuite vous
parcourez toute une liste de termes
journalistiques qui sont importants pour
les régulateurs du journalisme vous
détruisez un certain nombre de mythes
comme l'exactitude la justesse
expliquez-nous
et bien je ne sais pas si je les ai
détruit et je pense que les journalistes
doivent tendre vers l'exactitude
mais il ya un certain nombre de
problématiques si vous êtes un
régulateur le changement climatique en
serait une
le conflit israélo palestinien une autre
toutes ces problématiques sujette à
controverses sont difficiles pour les
régulateurs
quand on fait appel à eux je pourrais
même commencer par la hauteur de
l'everest qui est quelque chose sur
laquelle personne n'arrive à se mettre
d'accord donc l'exactitude vous savez
les journalistes apprennent pendant leur
première semaine en école de journalisme
ce qu'est le journalisme c'est plus
compliqué qu'on le croit pour la
justesse la justesse est à mon sens une
bonne chose l'impartialité est une bonne
chose mais c'est un mot controversé la
question est entre qui est sur quel
sujet et vous
impartial vous parlez de la justesse
comme d'une technique et l'exactitude
comme d'un bourbier
cela me semble aussi pertinent
maintenant que quand je les écris vous
définissez aussi les experts des gens
qui connaissent qui connaît si bien un
sujet qu'ils admettent leur propre
ignorance on a traversé une drôle de
période avec les experts n'est ce pas il
ya une sorte de révolte populiste contre
les experts le ministre michael gouv a
dit de manière mémorable
on en a assez des experts mais les
experts sont à nouveau à la mode et
c'est compréhensible car à qui
allez-vous faire confiance au sujet
d'une pandémie
la tendance selon les sondages et dans
la mesure où si on peut croire les
sondages de nos jours les gens sont
rassurés à la vue d'individus bardé de
diplômes et qui semble savoir de quoi il
parle
au delà de la pandémie quoique pas
vraiment puisque tony blair est
manifestement conseiller du gouvernement
sur le court aux navires us comment
voyez-vous la manière avec laquelle les
rédactions met en avant certaines
personnes et pas d'autres je veux dire
tony blair est un criminel de guerre
présumé qui offre ses conseils en tant
qu'ancien premier ministre
je pense que je préférais probablement
entendre le point de vue des
scientifiques sur cette question mais je
pense que blair méritent d'être écoutés
pour venir au coeur du livre
quelles sont les raisons que nous
donnons aux gens de se tourner à nouveau
vers le journalisme
si on vit dans un océan de fausses
informations
quelles sont nos arguments pour montrer
que nous sommes ce qu'il faut croire et
l'une de ses raisons et je pense que
nous avons du discernement quant aux
gens vers lesquels nous nous tournons
pour avoir une expertise
je donne beaucoup d'exemples dans le
livre de cas où des gens sont
controversés ou amusant
provocateur mais nos savants réalité
rien dû sujet dont ils parlent ils sont
trop souvent choisi parce qu'ils seront
divertis sens parce qu'ils vont faire en
sorte que les gens cliquent non parce
que leurs paroles a de la valeur je
pense que cela nuit à la confiance du
public dans les médias
d'accord mais on peut dire que bien plus
effrayant et la mention d'une
personnalité du journalisme pôle
d'accueil or dès que youssef vous parlez
d'un code du silence
qu'est ce qu'un code du silence y at il
un code du silence dans les médias
britanniques
ce à quoi je faisais référence c'est à
ma conviction que les médias constituent
une force très puissante de la société
et toutes les forces puissantes de la
société mérite d'être examinée mais je
sais d'expérience que quand nous avions
une section média ou guardian et en
particulier quand on a commencé à
regarder du côté du point faible des
médias britanniques
les scandales des écoutes téléphoniques
par exemple nous avons été fortement
encouragé à ne pas nous y intéresser
donc il sent qu'il y est une règle pour
les médias il faut être unis ne devrions
pas écrire au sujet de nos confrères et
une règle pour d'autres forces
puissantes de la société et je ne pense
pas que ce soit une bonne chose curieuse
vous pensez que les choses ont changé
pour les téléspectateurs de par le monde
on parle là du piratage d'un téléphone
d'une écolière assassinée qui a mené l
enquête publique de l'essonne et à la
fin du plus important journal anglophone
news of the world a bien j'espère que ça
change et je serais surpris si ce type
d'agissements criminels avait encore
cours dans les rédactions de nos jours
je pense que n'importe quel journaliste
qui penseraient intercepté des messages
les appels téléphoniques ou internet
vous comprendrez que c'est criminel et
il pourrait finir en prison comme ça a
été le cas pour d'autres journalistes
donc j'espère que cela a pris fin de la
même manière qu'il y a des choses
fabuleuses dans le journalisme au
royaume uni
il y a toujours des choses qui selon moi
ne vont pas et j'espère avoir été juste
avec ces deux aspects vous critiquez
beaucoup les médias détenus par les
oligarques le concept d'oligarchie dans
les médias vous savez nous vivons à une
époque il n'importe qui peut communiquer
4 milliards de personnes sont connectées
de par le monde les gens veulent savoir
qui chapeaute tout cela qui sont ces
personnes qui possèdent des rédactions
des studios et qui usent de ce privilège
pour imposer leur vision au public
les gens sont en droit de se demander
d'aller de qui s'agit-il seulement est
maintenant au 21ème siècle
j'imagine que vous devez faire attention
je veux dire vous avez dit tout le monde
peut dire ce qu'il veut et bien de toute
évidence le président des états unis ne
peut pas dire tout ce qu'il veut vous
êtes au conseil de surveillance de
facebook et d'autres réseaux sociaux
donc vous devez faire attention vous
n'avez peut-être pas encore eu de
réunion mais pouvez vous me dire ce que
vous pensez de la censure et de la
fermeture des comptes du président je
pense que c'est une question très
délicate et vous avez raison je pense
que ce sera une question qui sera
étudiée par le conseil de surveillance
mais vous savez de manière générale la
problématique est qu un président le
président démocratiquement élu d'un pays
qui a une grande tradition de liberté
d'expression 1 je pense le droit évident
d'être entendus et les gens le droit de
l'entendre pour se faire une idée à son
sujet tout ce qui laisse penser qu'il a
été censurée doit être combattue et cela
fonctionne uniquement jusqu'au moment où
il se met à utiliser ses comptes sur les
réseaux sociaux pour faire ce qu'il
semble avoir fait la semaine dernière et
dans les semaines qui ont précédé
c'est à dire un site et j'ai une
certaine sympathie pour la façon avec
laquelle twitter c'est en fin de compte
comportez vous ne pensez pas plutôt que
c'est si vous êtes un plutôt cra de la
silicon valley qu'un nouveau présent
arrive vous allez faire de votre mieux
pour attaquer son opposant afin d'éviter
de nouvelles régulations lors du mandat
de john dryden
c'est une manière très cynique de voir
les choses
je ne connais pas les gens qui ont pris
la décision mais je suppose que ça n'est
pas ce qui les ya peu c'est je suppose
que c'était leur grande inquiétude quant
à ce qui allait se passer pendant les 11
jours à venir cynique mais le livre est
plein de mention de la différence entre
cynisme et scepticisme
j'espère ne pas être cynique le
scepticisme est une bonne chose
le cynisme pas tellement vous êtes de
toute évidence un expert de quelque
chose d'autre
je veux parler de julian assange qui est
détenu dans la prison de belmarsh dans
votre nouveau livre vous le mentionnez
une vingtaine de fois vous le qualifiez
deux hackers cachottier de quelqu'un qui
adore les caméras vous le dites
irréfléchie le considérer comme un
intermédiaire de la direction de l'état
major des forces armées russes jiegu
vous n'aimez pas julian assange vient
tout cela a été documentée nous nous
sommes brouillés après avoir travaillé
ensemble sur les révélations de 2010
2011 et j'ai toujours dit que je le
défendrai pour le travail que nous avons
accompli ensemble et je l' ai défendu je
l' ai d'ailleurs aussi défendu dans sa
lutte contre son extradition
[Musique]
je pense que quelles que soient ses
erreurs du passé
il ne devrait pas être extradé quant à
ce qu'il a fait en 2016 je suis plus
dubitatif
et ce n'est pas ce qui lui est reproché
donc on peut le prendre en considération
mais il doit être défendu pour ce qui
lui est reproché
la juge vanessa barrette serre a été
très clair sur ce qu'elle considère
comme étant les erreurs de julian
assange il ne peut pas être extradé à
cause du risque de suicide
mais le président peut demander de vous
extradé vous parce que vous avez fait
bien essayons de voir les choses ainsi
il y a trois catégories différentes
d'information et la première est le type
d'informations sur lesquels nous avons
travaillé ensemble et dont nous avons
publié une partie en éditant tout ce qui
pourrait causer du tort je n'ai vu
personne critique et une telle attitude
ensuite julian a publié toutes les
archives ce qui est une chose différente
nous l'avions critiqué à l'époque et la
troisième c'est tout ce qui est arrivé
en 2016
ce que personne ne pourrait considérer
comme du journalisme
chrome est de la transmission de
matériaux qui avaient été piratées
nous entrons sur un terrain compliqué
auquel je m'attaque dans le livre en
posant la question sur les sources
les journalistes sont habitués à avoir
des sources qui elles mêmes peuvent
avoir des raisons discutables ou qui
sont d'origine douteuse
est ce que ça implique que l'information
n'a pas de valeur ont continué la
discussion avec l'ancien rédacteur en
chef du guardian
après cette courte pause
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec l'ancien
rédacteur en chef du guardian alan
rusbridger je ne sais pas si vous avez
entendu l'ancien ministre des finances
grec yannis varoufakis diack assange
aurait eu la grâce de donald trump s'il
avait admis que ce n'était pas les
russes et assange dit que ce n'était pas
les russes mais il ne veut pas dire la
vérité à qui que ce soit car elle dit
croire au journalisme et il ne veut pas
nuire à la moindre source qu'il est prêt
à mourir pour ça je ne sais pas grand
chose à ce sujet je sais que certains
doutes ont été levés dans l' enquête sur
donald trump qui a été menée par robert
müller mais je n'en sais pas assez pour
dire avec certitude
il a obtenu ces informations on peut
miser sur un certain nombre de scénarios
quant à l'origine des informations sur
les personnes qui les ont piraté
car c'était de toute évidence des
matériaux piratés illégalement et cela
pose de graves questions morales non
seulement pour d'autres personnes comme
un singe dans ce monde mais aussi pour
les médias comme le new york times ou le
washington post qui ont utilisé ces
documents je ne suis pas sûr que ça ait
été piraté illégalement mais vous
choisissez d'employer ce terme
pour ce qui est des crimes de guerre en
irak ces documents là non ce n'est pas
la question
c'était pour ce qui est de la loire
l'acte d'espionnage américains obtenus
illégalement comme l'ont été les
matériaux d'edouard snowdon c'est pour
cela que je dis qu'il n'ya pas de
réponse facile mon point de vue en tant
que rédacteur en chef était qu'il
fallait prendre en compte les matériaux
eux mêmes plus que les motivations de
ceux qui font fuiter l'information qui
ne sont pas tout à fait pertinente
la question est ce que les matérieux que
vous avez devant vous sont d'une
importance suffisante pour le public
pour que cela mérite d'être publié je
pense que la meilleure règle sur un
journaliste est d'examiner les matériaux
en mettant tout le reste de côté et de
se demander si l'information en elle
même a de la valeur
je ne pense pas que quiconque au
washington post
woodward et bernstein se préoccuper des
motivations de marc feld dit gorges
profondes
ça a été des informations importantes et
ils ont eu raison de les publier
c'est pourquoi on doit être très prudent
pour ce qui relève du secret d'état
une des choses qui me dérange dans la
loi contre l'espionnage et la
législation britannique contre la
violation des secrets d'état tels qu'ils
existent et qu'ils n'offrent à l'accusé
aucun moyen de se défendre
si vous ne pouvez pas dire c'est bien
j'ai fait ça parce que j'ai considéré ça
comme important et nécessaire ça n'est
pas pris en considération
je pense qu'on en sait assez sur le
comportement des états ce quel qu'il
soit il arrive qu'ils se comportent sans
aucun scrupule et leur définition de ce
qu'est la sécurité nationale ou
l'intérêt public ne résiste pas toujours
à l'épreuve du temps avez vous eu une
conversation avec vos autres confrères
du new york times du beagle de toutes
ces rédactions dans le monde parce qu'il
est probable que vous personnellement et
d'autres ancien rédacteur en chef puisse
y être extradé vers les états unis et
bien techniquement ça pourrait être vrai
mais comme je le disais l'exercice
auquel j'ai pris part sur ces médias
impliqués un très gros travail de
rédaction de sélection et de soin pour
ne créer de problème à personne et la
rédaction ne faisait pas partie de cette
affaire je veux dire la rédaction
n'était pas visée par le jugement rendu
le problème était que ces documents
avaient été saisis
oui oui et bien et publiée en masse
c'est ce qui me vient à l'esprit
et ça nous ramène à la question de
savoir ce qu'est le journalisme
selon la définition classique du
journalisme ce que nous faisions alors
que nous étions en train d'adapter le
contextualiser en choisissant de ne pas
publier certains documents
c'était faire des choix éditoriaux cela
diffère un peu ou plutôt beaucoup de
justes tout balancer sur internet c'est
différent le public où certaines
personnes peuvent estimer que ce serait
mieux
mais ce serait totalement différent de
ce que nous faisions nous et vous
considérez que c'est ce que julian
assange a fait car je sais qu en second
lieu vous faisait référence à la
déclaration de partenaires du guardian
nous déplorons la décision de wikileaks
de publier les télégrammes non édité ce
qui pourrait représenter une menace pour
les sources
je sais qu'en 2016 vous aviez quitté le
guardian
mais cette déclaration qui a été citée
par vanessa paré de cers pour dirk
assange devait être extradé
s'il n'y avait pas de risque de suicide
et le spiegel semble revenir en arrière
argument que cryptum avait diffusé ces
télégrammes non éditées et qu'il ne
connaissait pas tous les faits n'était
ce pas à votre beau frère qui était le
rédacteur en chef d enquête du guardian
ils ont sorti le mot de passe pour ces
documents eh bien il ya manifestement
des profs qui sont apparues au tribunal
et dont je ne suis pas au courant
parce qu'en réalité ça a été un procès
assez mal couvert ses auditions sur
l'extradition d'assange
donc il y a peut être des choses que je
ne connais pas ces décisions à l'époque
de prendre nos distances avec ce café
assange était évidente
nous avions passé des mois des années
même à travailler sur ces documents pour
les publier en toute sécurité
donc ça n'avait aucun sens pour nous de
publier ensuite l'intégralité en fait le
spiegel a dit à la cour
oui avec le guardian nous nous sommes
exprimés mais nous déplorons cette
décision car nous n'avions pas eu toutes
les informations
fact
puisqu'en réalité julian assange n'a pas
publier les télégrammes non éditées avec
le mot de passe ce sont d'autres
personnes qui ont fait cela je veux
parler de choses que je ne connais pas
car comme je les dis la couverture du
procès n'a malheureusement pas été assez
détaillés pour que je puisse savoir ce
qui a été dit mais étant donné que vous
savez que le guardian n'a pas bougé de
ligne contrairement au spiegel qui a dit
en fait on est assez désolé où ils
n'avions pas tous les faits lorsque nous
avons déploré la décision de julian
assange vient de ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ne s'agit pas du spiegel
en tant qu'entité je crois que c'était
l'un des journalistes qui a travaillé là
dessus je n'ai pas connaissance de
rédacteur en chef qui étaient impliqués
à l'époque qui serait revenu sur cette
déclaration
avez vous été surpris qu'en fin de
compte ce soit un article du guardian
que vanessa barrette sert site pour
expliquer pourquoi ce genre de travail
doit être puni par une extradition
encore une fois j'ai suivi sa décision
sur twitter mais au moment où je disais
son jugement il n'avait pas été publié
je ne sais pas s'il a été publié il faut
que je me penche dessus
pensez vous qu'il a été torturé comme
l'affirment le rapporteur spécial de
l'onu
je l' ai entendu parler à londres ce
devait être il ya un an et je les
trouvais très convaincant je les
trouvais vous savez et c'est quelqu'un
de sérieux et le mot torture n'est pas
de ceux que j'approuverai les il a de
toute évidence rencontré assange a parlé
à des docteurs qui l'ont vu il a été
très préoccupés par la santé mentale et
physique d'assange
parce qu'il a dit dans cette émission
que ce sont des articles du guardian qui
ont contribué à la torture psychologique
d'assange faisant référence à marina
ride qui très sérieusement pouvez
réprimer un curieux sourire suffisant à
l'idée de voir assange détenu alors
qu'il cherchait l'asile politique
pourquoi le guardian s'en est il pris à
sa propre source eh bien je pense que
julian a un caractère suffisamment bien
trempé pour ne pas être aussi blessé par
des articles du guardian pour être tout
à fait honnête
quoi qu'il en soit vous avez dit dans
des interviews que vous en étiez de
toute évidence très fier
l'un des plus grands scoops
journalistique de ces trente dernières
années vous citez la description par
vanity fair de ce que vous avez fait ce
travail comme le travail sur snowdon je
suis fier de ce que nous avons fait je
pense que c'était quelque chose
d'important et je pense qu'on l'a bien
fait une autre chose que vous mentionnez
dans le livre iii journaliste john
pilger seymour hersh feu roberts fils
qui sont tous passés dans cette émission
pourquoi isoler ces trois journalistes
il s'agit là de la question de savoir en
qui s confiance et si vous mettez à la
place du lecteur et que vous dites je
peux croire une marque je croirai
toujours ce que je peux lire dans le
daily telegraph ou dans le guardian ou
sur rt vous pouvez dire il y à certains
journalistes en qui j'ai pleinement
confiance et j'ai choisi des
journalistes qui ont fait un travail
remarquable
c'est une évidence concernant les trois
journalistes que vous venez de
mentionner
ils ont fait un travail remarquable mais
en même temps j'ai conscience je suis
sûr que vous aussi qu'il y a des points
d'interrogation concernant leur
couverture de certains sujets et
beaucoup de journalistes et expriment
des doutes sur certains de leurs travaux
donc cela nous mène à la question
suivante si vous êtes un lecteur
ordinaire qui pouvez vous croire
si même certains de leurs collègues ne
crois pas tout à fait ce qu'il faut
j'essaie d'explorer cette épineuse
question y at il une méthode de travail
qui fait consensus et comment présentons
nous le journalisme comme quelque chose
en laquelle on
voir confiance sur petra vous ne pensez
pas que certains lecteurs de votre livre
on souhaitait parce que vous mettez en
évidence des controverses et mais en fin
de compte vous parlez comme l'un d'entre
nous je ne sais pas si j'en fais partie
et c'est comme si vous distribuer les
bons et les mauvais points à ses trois
journalistes
je pense que c'est le problème fisc est
un journaliste robert fisk qui est mort
il y à peu depuis que j'ai écrit ce
livre était un journaliste que
j'admirais pour nombre de raisons mais
quand je me suis penché sur une ou deux
de ses couvertures ce qui implique et
journée de travail parce que vous
immerger dans le monde d'internet où des
gens le défendent ou des gens le
critiquent
vous pouvez aller à la source d'origine
dans certains cas ils viennent y passer
des heures à lire des récits
contradictoires quant aux matériaux
qu'ils utilisaient mais en fin de compte
la plupart d'entre nous finissions assez
choqué par penser eh bien je ne sais pas
je ne sais quoi croire ce qui nous
ramène au début de cette conversation
la plupart des gens qui n'ont pas le
moins du monde le temps de faire quelque
chose comme ça sont en position je pense
de dire je ne sais pas et dans un sens
ça a été la tactique dont a délibérément
usées donald trump et il s'en ait
délibérément pris aux meilleurs médias
en disant qu'il ne fallait pas les
croire impliquant par là
vous feriez bien aussi de me croire moi
car la vérité n'existe pas la vérité est
aussi valable que la leur vous vous
souvenez de l'expression de fai
alternatifs
c'est une tactique consciente très
dangereuse faire en sorte que les gens
parce qu'ils ne peuvent croire en quoi
que ce soit finissent par vouloir croire
n'importe quoi
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire je ne
suis pas sûr qu'on puisse tout mettre
sur le dos de donald trump et feu robert
fisk ne peut se défendre
il faut ici que j'avoue avoir été l'un
des plus jeunes
éditorialiste du guardian sous peter
preston
et pendant une petite partie de votre
carrière en tant que rédacteur en chef
mais je voudrais terminer sur la peur
car vous en tant que rédacteur en chef
vous avez décidé de publier les
incroyable révélation des douars snowdon
sur la surveillance de masse je suppose
que vous avez été forcé de laisser
entrer des hauts fonctionnaires dans vos
locaux avec des services spéciaux qu'ils
détruisent un ordinateur portable à
aucun moment avez-vous le sentiment que
les choses prenaient l'apparence d'un
cauchemar soviétique
et bien ce qu'on a fait c'est transférer
notre publication à new york
on a travaillé depuis new york où ils
ont le premier amendement donc on
comprenait bien qu'il serait très peu
probable que quelqu'un vienne dans nos
locaux de new york
c'est pourquoi on les a laissé détruire
les disques à londres je n'étais pas
fier du comportement du gouvernement et
j'aimerais qu'on est un système plus
robustes plus à l'américaine de
protection des médias afin que les
gouvernements ne puisse pas agir ainsi
mais en fin de compte ça n'a altéré en
rien ce que nous étions en train de
publier
etiez-vous compte en cassant je vais
faciliter sa fuite vers moscou
je ne sais pas assez de choses
concernant qui a aidé qui à l'époque je
suppose qu'ils se sont mutuellement td
assange et snowdon se sont faits
discrets quant à comment tout cela s'est
passé mais je suis bien sûr content tu
les douars snowdon vive
heureusement à moscou et qu'il soit
maintenant père ce sont de bonnes
nouvelles
alan rusbridger remercie beaucoup votre
livre est maintenant disponible
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui à la
prochaine en réponse aux allégations
faites dans cette interview
kristinn hrafnsson rédacteur en chef de
wikileaks affirmait la publication du
guardian sur les télégrammes induit les
partenaires en erreur et a été conçu
pour passer sous silence ses propres
actions irresponsables qui ont conduit
au dumping de télégrammes non censurée
sur cryptome et the pirate bay cette
publication affecte leur réputation tout
comme leur célèbre couverture qui
prétend à tort que paul mara fort
l'associé de trump a rendu visite à
julian assange
[Musique]